the orille first of all I'm going to
tell you that 11 out of 15 of the people
I asked said that no they do not think
the orille is going to return in 2014 or
even be announced now we've talked about
this a lot and there has been a bit of a
roller
coaster sometimes it looked like the
orille was going to return and other
times it looked like it didn't for me I
am going to say that look it is still
possible that the Orville might return
for another season I still say as again
many of my sources have been telling me
for a while now that Seth McFarland will
probably not return for full season he's
so busy with other projects He may not
even write the series he would have to
basically give his Blessing to be taken
over by somebody else I think there are
several actors that might not return and
I actually think that it would be a
completely different sort of show if it
did come back I'm being told there are
people over at Disney that would
absolutely love for this to come back
and they